jean lassalle a fait annuler tous les
votes de son village au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle on t'explique
pourquoi en fait c'est le conseil
constitutionnel qui l'a décidée après la
publication d'une vidéo jean lassalle
met en scène son abstention au deuxième
tour de la présidentielle la scène se
déroule dans la commune jean lassalle a
été maire pendant plus de 40 ans je veux
en diffusant cette vidéo sur ces réseaux
sociaux le jour de l'élection jean
lassalle a selon le conseil
constitutionnel diffuser des messages à
caractère de propagande électorale alors
qu'ils étaient strictement interdit de
le faire du samedi 23 avril au dimanche
24 avril le conseil constitutionnel
l'accusent également d'avoir porté
atteinte au respect dû à la dignité des
opérations électorales ces agissements
ont eu égard à la notoriété de monsieur
la salle à lourdios ichère était de
nature à altérer la sincérité du scrutin
dans sept communes conséquence les 90
suffrages exprimés dans le village ont
été annulés par le conseil
constitutionnel